[Musique]
nous sommes gravement préoccupés par les
fêtes d'extrême violence qui continuent
à d'échapper à toute contrôle en été
les affrontants sont de plus en plus
violents et de plus en plus fréquents
car il tente d'entendre leur contrôle
territorial dans la capitale et dans
d'autres régions en prenant de plus en
plus pour cibles les personnes vivantes
dans les uns contre les rivaux
[Musique]
on parle là de la violence faite aux
femmes faites aux filles la violence
sexuelle la violence qui est qui la
population regarde comme c'est
impressionnant de la situation en Haïti
et donc c'est une crise de protection
Christ de droits de l'homme